rumors of a Harry Potter reboot have
been circulating for years and in April
of 2023 WB finally confirmed it is in
fact happening but what exactly do we
know so far what are the rumors versus
the facts people of the internet retrans
who are here and in this video I'll be
covering everything we know so far about
the Harry Potter reboot everything
starts with Max formerly known as HBO
Max which will be the home for a new
television series a retelling of the
original 7 Harry Potter books early
rumors said one book per season but now
we know that won't be the case Max
announced their plans for this to be a
decade long series over the course of
the next decade David wanted me to make
sure you heard me say next decade 10
years my guess would be the first few
books will match the one book per one
season rate but once we hit Goblet of
Fire in order of the Phoenix I would
expect things to stretch out a bit more
all of this will ultimately be decided
by the writers and showrunners once
they're in place it's also important to
keep in mind the series is very much in
the early stages of development with no
writers or cast in place as of early
2024 given this information many don't
believe will see the series until late
2025 at the earliest but more likely
sometime in 2026 the series is not
expected to delve into the events of the
Fantastic Beast films which focused on a
younger Albus Dumbledore and the rise of
the Dark wizard grindewald oh and also
that NES Commander guy now producer
David hymon is one of the men who played
a significant role in originally
bringing the series to the big screen he
produced all eight of the Potter movies
and each of the three fantastic Beast
films early reports say that discussions
are currently ongoing about bringing him
back to produce this new adaptation on
the other hand David Yates who directed
the final four Potter films and three
fantastic Beast movies is not expected
to be involved with the television
series as for the cast fans should
prepare for completely new faces none of
the original actors are expected to
reprise their roles there are some
rumors we could see cameos and even
speculation about previous actors in new
roles such as Tom Felton possibly taking
on the role of Lucius Malfoy on the
other hand Harry Potter actor Daniel
Radcliffe told comicbook.com my
understanding is that they're trying to
very much start fresh and I'm sure
whoever is making them will want to make
their own mark on it and probably not
want to have to figure out how to get
old Harry to cameo in this somewhere
Ratcliffe went on to say so I'm
definitely not seeking it out in any way
but I do wish them obviously all the
luck in the world and I'm very excited
to to have that torch passed but I don't
think it needs me to physically pass it
of course fans online have enjoyed
speculating and giving their own dream
lists of actors and actresses they'd
like to see in these iconic roles if
you've heard or seen specific names and
people claiming that they're confirmed
that is absolutely not the case don't
get me wrong there are plenty of rumors
out there but we've seen no confirmation
from WB or author JK rolling speaking of
rolling she is confirmed to be involved
as the executive producer she put out a
statement with the announcement saying
Max's commitment to preserving the
Integrity of my books is important to me
and I'm looking forward to being part of
this new adaptation which will allow for
a degree of depth and detail only
afforded by a long form television
series Max's chairman and CEO echoed
rolling statement in assured fans the
plan for this series is to dive deep
into each of the iconic books and that
it would be a faithful adaptation of the
original series now while those films
are beloved by fans around the world
there's no denying the extensive cuts
that had to be made to bring them to the
big screen hopefully a decade long TV
series will be able to explore some of
the more intricate plot details and even
characters that didn't make it into the
movies I'm one of those people who
really appreciates the original series
and everything they did to bring the
World of Harry Potter to life but I also
feel they pale in comparison to the
books there were so many details the
movies left out others they changed
significantly and even main characters
who were changed to fit the mold of
Hollywood writers one of the most
obvious examples of this is Ron Weasley
a character the movies used most mostly
for comic relief why couldn't it be
follow the butterflies Neville long
bottom plays a much more prominent role
in the first few books than he does the
movies and how can we forget the
relationship between Harry and Jenny
which never had the same chemistry on
screen as it did in the books there's
also the complete absence of the
Marauder's backstory as well as
significant details about Tom Riddle's
childhood then you have Half Blood
Prince which does very little to explain
the meaning behind that title and why
that reveal of it being Snape is such an
important moment for Harry don't even
get me started on the attack on the
burough then you have the characters
that didn't make it into the films at
all like peeves Charlie Weasley winky
the house elf Professor grubbly Plank
and several others so hopefully we'll
get to see a story that does a better
job with those specific issues now I
know there were a lot of fans who
weren't too excited when this
announcement first dropped after all
deathly Hallow's part two just released
in 2011 of course you do have the fact
that the original cast and the
characters they played are so incredibly
iconic with many of them being
synonymous with those roles do we really
need a Harry Potter reboot personally I
would have preferred seeing spin-offs
stories or even a series focused on
Harry's life after Hogwarts but
admittedly they kind of already tried
this with the Fantastic Beast movies and
the cursed child stage play there were a
number of issues with both of those but
I hope that doesn't prevent them from
trying again at some point down the road
I think there are so many Rich stories
waiting to be told in this world but
they have to go about them in the right
way that being said I still am looking
forward to the TV series I was one of
those people who was a fan of the books
long before they were turned into movies
so I think that maybe why I'm looking at
the series with maybe a little more
optim ISM than most now one question you
may be asking is why now well one of the
big reasons we're finally seeing this is
a renewed Focus from Warner Brothers
Discovery to Showcase their biggest
franchises of which Harry Potter is
certainly one of them president and CEO
David zaslov has made it very clear he
wants to be doing more with their most
iconic characters and this has been a
focus of his since the merger of Warner
media and discovery that happened back
in April of 2022 this is who we are this
is what we do we tell stories it's not
just a new television series though when
it comes to the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter WB is looking to capitalize on
the immense success of the video game
Hogwarts Legacy which sold more than 22
million copies last year recent comments
from a top WB executive dropped a few
hints as to what fans can expect and
I've already broken that down here in
another video definitely check that one
out next also I want to give a big shout
out to all of our house wck and tour
members who help make these videos
possible you can become a member too by
looking for the join button below this
video as always thank you all so much
for watching let's talk to you again
soon